i was bringing up you know
what's going on in palestine in gaza
um it's a a complicated
situation but it's also really like on a
human level
aspect it doesn't seem very complicated
yeah i don't i don't think it's
it's very complicated um
you know for palestinians
it's been a struggle for a long time and
um it's like this this like cycle keeps
repeating
over and over you know i mean it's like
it's hard to see
real change happen when people
aren't being told you know the whole
story about what's really happening over
there
you know what i mean and again you know
like i really feel like
uh it comes down to it comes down to
people having to hold their governments
accountable
and that's i think that's the only way
we could change
you know the the status quo the way they
even perceive us and look at us and
stuff like that is like
you know it's dehumanizing end of the
day
it's like uh you know
palestinian people some of the most
resilient people in the world
of course gone through some of the worst
atrocities
and all anyone's asking for that anyone
that's speaking out all anyone's asking
for is
some compassion some compassion some
human rights
and you know not not to see the
situation through
biased eyes to actually just look and
do the proper research and then you can
come up with your own answer
you know yeah i mean from what i've
gathered is like
obviously what transpired during ramadan
um how the like you know i
i spoke to uh my friend adam rice who's
jewish and his
his parents go to israel every single
year and he was like we're wrong in this
thing man like
what did like like why would you
do that to those people during their
holiest time and
expect like things like you know what i
mean like like nobody like would ever
think to do that and expect anything
good to happen of it you know what i
mean
and even peter rosenberg who you know
again is obviously a jewish man you know
what i mean me and peter talked about it
pretty extensively yes my god and he
married kind of mirrored the same
thoughts you know and i think
it kind of comes down to like you said
holding your government accountable in
the same way that
if donald trump's a piece of [ __ ] and
somebody from
[ __ ] europe is like man donald
trump's a piece of [ __ ]
that doesn't mean the americans are
pieces of [ __ ] it means that
yo you know and i've heard that the guy
who and again i'm not like the craziest
like
as far as like who's like being educated
on
the ins and outs of the government in
israel but i've heard
from people who i trust that like yo
essentially the guy who's
running [ __ ] in israel is like their
version of trump like hardcore right
wing like
crazy like crazy neocon
type ass [ __ ] so yeah it's just
rough man because like you see some of
these images of these people and it's
like dude like
this i mean his his own government is
holding him accountable and
he just got ousted from his position a
few days ago see i didn't know that yeah
uh
you know he's on corruption charges
being accused of bribery you know it's
all kind of this is
not a it's not a a
favorable human you know what i'm saying
so
it's easy to see how somebody like that
could really
you know put poison the well you know
yeah and i think too what people have to
understand too and this i've always said
this about america like just in general
like
yo like if you're what do you expect to
happen
if you're like imagine if you're a kid
in gaza right and somebody
bombed the building you live in and
let's say you lost your mom
like what do you expect that kid to grow
up feeling about
you know what i'm saying it's almost
like it's a cycle that'll never
end until it ends yeah i mean
you know to me i i feel like it's just
gonna have to come down to people
just just looking at it as a human issue
yeah politics on the side
you know there's there's civilians kids
dying
you know and the thing the thing about
the whole
you know we're we're going to hunt a
specific
militia or whatever right and it's like
i'm all for it you you you want to go uh
find some some criminals or whatever the
case is and not in that
particular situation i'm talking just in
general vaguely yeah
you know but um
you you shouldn't be killing civilians
to go get to the people
that you're mad at for killing civilians
like it doesn't make any sense there's
got to be a better way
to approach all of this which is also
what happened with the united states
like obama
and the drones and i mean this [ __ ] has
like happened so much where it's like yo
at what point in time
is getting the bad guy worth killing a
bunch of innocent kids
you know what i mean like this is crazy
because again it's like who suffers bro
yeah and then and then and then it's
almost like the psycho gets hit
on repeat because imagine all i can only
imagine if i grew up somewhere and
someone
some my parents or my sister died or my
best friend died like how i would feel
about
whoever the [ __ ] did that for the rest
of my life and it's like it's just never
i you know
it's just it's almost like the gang [ __ ]
you know what i mean like we always talk
i i talk to the homies who are
you know gang bangers out here and and
like i'll be like yo like what is the
like how's the violence he's like how
are you gonna tell somebody to not turn
up on that crew when they
they they took their brother or cousin
well you know what i mean it's it's like
what
like you said it's got to be a human
rights thing man and i think
unfortunately i wish like our government
would have stepped in and done more but
like you said earlier it's like that
politics [ __ ] comes into play
again once you throw all that politic
[ __ ] you know out the window
and that's why i wish we had bernie man
and you just stop and you and you have
some emphasis you [ __ ] with bernie
right hell yeah
yeah i thought i think bernie's like the
illest [ __ ] like he should have
been our president
bro oh yeah bernie's great man he's
jewish right like
and he don't give a [ __ ] like he's like
yo it's about human rights yeah this is
what this thing ain't about is the thing
is it's not about
being jewish right no but you know what
you're right and we know that and we can
have that conversation but
the internet and twitter and it's like
you're either there or you're here no
there's no in the middle
bro i got people from all walks of life
so do i jewish muslim
christian catholic buddhist whatever you
want to name
atheist whatever you want to name 100
that
i consider some people i consider family
friends
colleagues co-workers whatever
um that to me never
stop means love for you it'll never stop
my support for you it'll never stop
nothing everybody just has a stop
and look at it from a human
issue take the tribal the tribal [ __ ]
away take the take all the political
peoples government take all the all the
bias
all the things you want to feel take
those away and just be like yo let's
just look at what's going on here
you know what i mean no matter where you
are and what country you're from
if you love your country you're gonna
hold your government accountable until
they're doing the right thing